there was a woman in chopped actually
who showed this perfectly this woman I
want her to run for Senate I don't know
who she is I don't know what her name is
I love her she's inside the chop
neighborhood she is a black woman she's
talking to a white liberal woman and
this white liberal woman presumably
before the cameras turned on was
espousing her stupid radical ideas and
then this young black woman was just
slowly explaining to this why everything
she thought be still my beating heart
oh my gosh when she gets to the sexual
revolution and feminism be still my
beating heart she makes a really great
point here I mean I encourage you to
watch there a number of videos of her we
don't have time to play the whole thing
she makes this really great point which
is white liberals and white leftist
radicals are foisting a lot of
radicalism on the black community so
cold that really historically has no
place there think about the LGBT
movement getting back to our
or a Supreme Court decision earlier in
the show don't forget the way that we
got gay marriage
meaning the radical redefinition of
marriage from what it had never meant to
now this new thing we didn't get it
through voting why didn't we get a
through voting they tried to do it
through voting remember they did prop 8
in California and part of the reason
that the redefinition of marriage was
defeated on that ballot initiative is
because black voters overwhelmingly
turned out against it for many many
years black voters did not support
redefining marriage they did not support
the kind of radical sexual revolutionary
leftism that you saw mostly from white
activists same thing with feminism I
love when she goes yeah listen white
liberal ladies your whole thing of like
feminism is great and you know I'm gonna
do what I want and we're not gonna have
any sort of respectful relations between
the sexes we don't do that that's not
that's not what we do and our point is
well-taken I don't know if it's well
taken by the white liberal lady but it
is well taken by everyone else this
point she makes on abortion it is true
but black women are disproportionately
likely to have abortions now but that is
by design their the the abortion
movement that began in the early 20th
century in earnest specifically targeted
black communities there is a reason why
Planned Parenthood disproportionately
sets up shop in black communities there
has been a plan okay and I what this
woman is recognizing she says this is
bad we should not wait I don't we don't
want to be killing our children this is
a bad idea this has been bad for our
community
[Music]